بالنسبة للإمارة نفسها، فهي تعزز
الأسطول بـ 90 طائرة بوينج 7 X على الرغم من أن
الخطة لن تطير أو تدخل
الأسطول لمدة عامين آخرين على الأقل
بعض طائرات 787 الإضافية وشركة فلاي دبي
التقطت أيضًا طائرات طويلة المدى ذات الجسم العريض لأول
مرة سألت تيم  كلارك من
طيران الإمارات، ما هو شعورك
عندما تنفق 52 مليار دولار على
الطائرات؟ هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
نقوم فيها بذلك، لقد فعلنا ذلك قبل 10 سنوات
عندما طلبنا 150 طائرة من
الموقع المحدد الذي طلبناه للتو و5380 طائرة كذلك.  وكان
هذا الطلب 90 مليارًا، لذا
فهذا طلب كبير ولكن هل قمنا بذلك
قبل نعم، هل تستمر المفاوضات
حتى اللحظة الأخيرة أم أن كل ذلك
تم قبل أسابيع وأنت في الحقيقة مجرد
ترقيع لا لا، نحن كذلك  ما زلنا
نتجادل حول القرعة في
الدقائق الأخيرة حول ما أنا عليه، ما هو السعر، هل يتم
تسليمه لا لأن الظروف
تتغير، كما تعلم أن الضغط يبدأ في
بناء الناس يطورون مواقفهم
التي ربما كانوا
متمسكين بها مدركين أن الخط على وشك  يتم
التجاوز فيما يتعلق بالجداول الزمنية وكل
شيء آخر لذلك لا يزال بإمكانك أه تم
الانتهاء من معظم المشكلات، وتم
الانتهاء من المشكلات الكبيرة ولكن هناك الكثير من المشكلات الأخرى
التي لا يزال يتعين حلها، والعديد
منها تجارية ولكنها ستصل إلى  في الساعة
الحادية عشرة، نرى أه تلك اللعبة الشهيرة
مع الدجاج، ولم تكن هناك طلبات من طائرات إيرباص، ولم تقم
بتنفيذ المزيد من طائرات 350 أو أجسام N
بعد، فهل هذا ما زال
قادمًا، وأعتقد أننا نجري
مناقشات تفصيلية معنا بشكل أساسي حول
350  لم نصل إلى هناك
بعد، وآمل أن نصل إلى هناك
خلال الـ 24 ساعة القادمة 24 يومًا 24
أسبوعًا، لا أعرف أن الكثير يعتمد عليهم،
لذا انتقل إلى الإستراتيجية الآن، ما هي
استراتيجية النمو التي تريدها؟  لقد تطورنا دائمًا
بسرعة نسبيًا ولكن بحذر ولكن
المنافسة تزداد حدة في
المنطقة، أنت تعرفني لم أواجه أبدًا
أشياء مثل تلك
الأسئلة التي طرحها عليّ أشخاص مثلك
منذ 20 عامًا حول تاريخ إنشاء IAD G
Airways  تم تشكيل أم
أن هناك مجالًا لثلاثة أشخاص، وكان
السؤال هو هل هناك مجال لهذا
وأعتقد أن الدليل على ذلك هو أنه
كان هناك مجال كبير لثلاثة أشخاص
لأن نماذج الأعمال هذه في
جوهرها هي نماذج أعمال دولية
تعتمد على التدفقات الدولية المتقاطعة
الفرق بين ذلك الحين
والآن هو أن دبي في هذه
الحالة بالذات قد انفجرت في نموها وفي
كل شيء آخر، لذا فقد أضافت زخمًا حقيقيًا
إلى نموذجنا